Trascrizione: Silvia Spolaore Mergaert
Revisore: Stefania Scardigli
(Applausi)
- Buonasera.
Secondo uno studio recente
pubblicato da 'Science'
le bambine, già a sei anni,
iniziano a pensare di essere meno brave
dei loro compagni maschi.
Quindi già dalla prima elementare
iniziano a credere che
i maschi siano più bravi di loro,
anche se non c'è
nessuna evidenza scientifica
ovviamante che lo dimostra, anzi
anche se al contrario di solito mediamente
a scuola sono proprio le femmine
a essere più brave.
Com'è possibile?
Chi gli ha messo in testa
che i maschi siano ontologicamente
più bravi di loro?
Una delle teorie più convincenti
per spiegare questo fenomeno
è quella del cosidetto
"curriculum nascosto".
Che sembra un po' il titolo
di una teoria cospirazionista,
ma in realtà non è così.
I libri per bambini,
i materiali didattici, i cartoni animati
i film per famiglie
non sono soltanto intrattenimento.
Servono ai bambini
a formare un'idea del mondo
e servono alla società a passare
di generazione in generazione i valori
che vengono considerati fondamentali
per lo sviluppo dell'umanità.
Se Cappuccetto Rosso
avesse ascoltato la mamma
non sarebbe stata mangiata dal lupo.
Ascolta la mamma!
Se i genitori
della Bella Addormentata nel Bosco
avessero invitato
la fatina anziana al battesimo
l'incantesimo
non si sarebbe abbattuto sul castello.
Rispettate gli anziani!
Ma quando si parla di personaggi femminili
quali sono i messaggi che stiamo mandando
alle bambine attraverso queste storie?
Lasciate che vi leggiamo
l'inizio di tre fiabe celeberrime:
Cenerentola, Biancaneve e Barbablu.
Cenerentola.
C'era una volta,
tanto tempo fa, una vedova
che aveva due figlie bruttine
e anche un po' antipatiche.
Biancaneve.
C'era una volta una bella principessa
di nome Biancaneve.
Aveva i capelli neri come l'ebano,
la bocca rossa come una rosa
e la carnagione bianca come la neve.
Barbablu.
C'era una volta un uomo molto ricco.
Per disgrazia quest'uomo
aveva la barba blu
e ciò lo rendeva così brutto e terribile
che non c'era donna o ragazza
che non scappasse vedendolo.
Una sua vicina, una gran signora,
aveva due figlie bellissime.
Egli ne domandò una in moglie,
lasciandole la scelta di dargli
questa o quella.
Gli stiamo dicendo prima di tutto,
costantemente,
che il loro valore come esseri umani
risiede nella loro bellezza.
Se non sei bella, non esisti.
Badate, se un uomo è brutto,
non solo può esistere
ma può diventare ricco,
si può sposare numerose volte,
disfarsi delle proprie mogli
misteriosamente
e nonostante questo nessuno
gli nega una nuova moglie.
Stiamo dicendo alle nostre bambine
che ritrovarsi sposate
con un uomo violento, ma ricco,
è meglio che non sposarsi affatto.
Pensate alla Bella e la Bestia.
La Bestia è un uomo così riprovevole
da essersi letteralmente
trasformato in una bestia.
Ma la Bella non scappa
a gambe levate dal castello
ma dedica la sua vita a redimerlo.
Quando vi chiedete
perché tante donne rimangono accanto
a uomini violenti così a lungo,
pensate al "curriculum nascosto".
Pensate che attraverso queste storie
questo è il sistema di valori
che stiamo passando alle nostre bambine.
Voi direte
che queste sono storie tradizionali
che i libri sono cambiati nel frattempo
che i bambini oggi
non leggono Barbablu.
Allora andiamo a vedere
un po' di dati e di numeri,
sui libri e la tv per bambini.
Una specie di fotografia
dei media per bambini
degli ultimi cinquant'anni.
Innanzitutto il cento per cento dei libri per bambini
hanno almeno un personaggio maschile.
Invece il venticinque per cento dei libri per bambini
non hanno neanche un personaggio femminile.
E quasi il quaranta per cento dei libri per bambini
non hanno neanche
un personaggio femminile parlante.
E infine, soltanto nel 18,5%
dei cartoni animati
i personaggi femmini hanno una professione
o ambizioni professionali,
contro oltre l'ottanta per cento
dei personaggi maschili.
Ora noi sappiamo
che i bambini utilizzano le storie
ovviamente per costruirsi un'idea
del mondo in cui vivono.
Utilizzano le fiabe e le storie
per capire come funzionano le cose
e qual è il loro ruolo nel mondo
e quali sono i loro compiti.
Ma che tipo di mondo genera
una letterature per l'infanzia
così severa nei confronti delle bambine?
È questa la domanda
che noi ci siamo chieste
quando abbiamo deciso di creare
"Storie della buonanotte
per bambine ribelli".
Abbiamo pensato a una letteratura
che trasmettesse alle bambine
modelli di coraggio,
di affermazione di sé,
di resilienza e di determinazione.
Esempi presi dal mondo reale
non dal regno della fantasia.
Abbiamo pensato
a una narrazione da trasmettere
di generazione in generazione
il cui obiettivo
fosse celebrare la femminilità
e i progresso dei diritti.
Una raccolta in cui le donne
non fossero in competizione
per sposare un principe,
ma formassero alleanze
per deporre tiranni,
come nel caso delle sorelle Mirabal.
Per scrivere la storia del tennis,
come nel caso delle sorelle Williams.
Una raccolta di fiabe
in cui le madri adottive
non cercassero disperatamente
di disfarsi delle proprie figlie,
ma le aiutassero a diventare
campionesse olimpioniche,
come nel caso della madre adottiva
di Simone Biles, la ginnasta americana.
Una raccolta in cui i mariti
non fossero mostri
che tengono in ostaggio le proprie figlie,
ma compagni di avventura,
come il marito di Alfonsina Strada
che il giorno del loro matrimonio
le regalò una bicicletta
perché aveva capito
di aver sposato una campionessa
e voleva solo vederla correre e vincere.
Non c'è niente di innocuo in una storia.
Una storia esprime
sempre una visione del mondo.
E una storia per bambini
a maggior ragione, esprime
una visione del mondo
che vogliamo costruire.
Quando la tradizione
però invece è oppressione
non bisogna temere di essere ribelli.
Siamo noi, d'altra parte,
a fare la cultura
e non è la cultura a fare noi.
Prendiamoci allora questa responsabilità
e diciamo
a tutte le bambine ribelli del mondo:
sognate più in grande,
puntate più in alto,
lottate con più energia.
E nel dubbio, ricordate,
avete ragione voi. Grazie.
(Applausi)
Grazie.